[Música]
e se alguém num sábado de manhã como
hoje perguntasse para cada um de vocês o
que você deseja
qual o seu objetivo de vida
o que te faz levantar a cada manhã
bom enquanto eu criava essa situação
hipotética na cabeça de vocês algumas
luzes se acenderam sobre algumas
palavras muito provavelmente a palavra
amor deva ter aparecido tema ter sido
iluminada
muito provavelmente a palavra sucesso
a palavra felicidade pois bem eu me fiz
essa pergunta também quando me preparava
pra conversar com vocês
e essas luzes também se acenderam sobre
essas palavras na minha própria cabeça
só que olhando um pouco mais de calma eu
pude observar que existia uma outra
palavrinha que era luminosa que talvez
nunca tivesse dado muita atenção para
ela mas ela se colocou como algo que eu
não posso ignorar
então eu quero dizer para vocês que o
meu objetivo de vida o motivo que me faz
levantar a cada dia
aquilo que eu desejo no fundo do meu
coração é sem dúvida alguma relevância e
pessoal nós não temos o direito de não
ser rei e levantes
eu preciso ser relevante e com a minha
família eu preciso ser relevante na
sociedade onde estou inserido eu preciso
ser relevante na minha profissão eu
preciso ser relevante no mundo tem uma
frase que eu acho muito legal
madre teresa de calcutá
o seguinte você não pode permitir que
alguém passe por você
sem se sentir tocado
você não pode permitir que alguém
conviva com você sem ser diferente dessa
convivência e relevante é fundamental
enquanto me preparava para essa fala e
me preparei como nunca e mesmo assim as
mãos tão geladas
a terra está tremendo e eu tenho um
iceberg no lugar do meu histórico mas
não tem problema eu queria tentar criar
uma figura que deixar muito claro a
importância de que sejamos relevantes ea
figura cíntia relevância
só pra nós aqui é que nem bacon outro
gosta ou tu tá errado
portanto ou você quer se relevante ou
você está errado
senti um pouco da importância da
relevância talvez em cima
essa metáfora não tenha sido tão feliz
assim
mas eu quero trazer um dado pra vocês e
porque nós precisamos ser relevantes
nós temos um planeta terra 7 bilhões e
400 milhões de habitantes
um dado recente da onu nos coloca que
nós temos condições nosso planeta terra
de dar vida digna para três milhões e
200 milhões de habitantes
portanto nós temos quatro milhões e 200
milhões de habitantes clamando pela sua
relevância 4 milhões e 200 milhões de
habitantes que não têm vida digna
adriano que a vida digna prática vida
digna pra mim é emprego é moradia é
alimento é é acesso a bens culturais é
saúde e segurança é poder num belo
sábado estar aqui no ted isso a vida
digna
isso é vida digna
portanto nós precisamos ser relevantes
eu gosto muito de uma frase de steve
jobs várias dele uma delas é a seguinte
ou você veio pra trás
formado mundo ou você veio para dar um
motor diz qo no universo ou eu não sei
por que você veio
eu não sei porque você vê isso nos
impele a ser relevantes precisamos ser
relevantes mas não somente nós temos que
ser relevantes as instituições nas quais
nós atuamos deve ser absolutamente
relevantes e nesse contexto de tantos
problemas a serem resolvidos não é
ignorância que vai fazer mas sim o
conhecimento e dentro dessa seara das
instituições que podem ser e devem ser
relevantes e um contexto de tantos
problemas a serem resolvidos sem dúvida
alguma as universidades as instituições
de ensino superior que formam os
profissionais que devem transformar o
mundo tem um poder muito grande e
precisa de fato ser relevantes
eu quero apresentar para vocês
esse rapaz aqui eu quero falar um pouco
sobre a história dessa criança criança
começou a sua história com ensino
superior há 36 anos atrás quando ele por
dois anos acompanhava entrava num
fusquinha 6 8 e 9 da sua mãe e
acompanhava a a até a universidade para
que ela pudesse fazer seu curso superior
e fazendo companhia para o outro e ele
lembra que ele brincou muito nos
corredores
ele tinha oito anos nessa época eu gosto
muito da história dessa criança
ele tinha oito anos nessa época ele
brincou muito desenhou muito não acessar
o facebook porque o marcos wainberg nem
tinha nascido ainda na época senão ele
teria acessado facebook sem dúvida
alguma ele dormiu muito assim como fez
depois fiquei sabendo na sua própria
faculdade
durante seu próprio curso superior e
também do rio mas ele pôde acompanhar de
dentro da sala de aula
a vivência da sua mãe quando a sua mãe
se formou quem entrou no curso superior
foi só ele pode ver uma pré-adolescente
quase adolescente fazendo um curso
superior ele acompanhou sem dúvida
alguma a vivência dela dentro da
universidade
bom todos nós temos a nossa vez e ele
teve sua vez também ele no seu tempo
prestou seu vestibular e ingressar num
curso de graduação e essa criança agora
já pré adolescentes viveu como ninguém a
universidade tanto que ele demorou oito
anos para se formar mas essa é uma outra
conversa
e essa criança ele fez participou de
projetos de extensão quem essas
disciplinas a ele foi estagiário dessa
universidade e de logo após ele foi
funcionário do setor mais importante de
qualquer instituição único setor onde as
pessoas que trabalham têm licença para
matar são 100 que é o uso da informática
não entrava desde a sala do reitor até o
computador mais escondido na sala mais
irmã da instituição ele podia ter acesso
liberado portanto conhecia todos os
setores de se formar antes de se formar
essa esse menino começou a dar aulas no
centro de ensino médio da universidade e
teve a sua primeira experiência como
docente quando se formou entrou
imediatamente no mestrado e quando
finalizou seu mestrado ele começou a ser
professor da graduação outra experiência
como professor de graduação
ele se habilita a fazer extensão a fazer
pesquisa e é também a assumir alguns
cargos administrativos estratégicos da
instituição
ao finalizar seu mestrado inglês ou
diretamente no seu doutorado onde pode
conhecer algumas universidades fora do
país porque que eu apresento a história
desse menino ea sua vinculação com o
ensino superior porque ele é uma pessoa
que conhece como poucos as engrenagens
de uma instituição de ensino superior e
os engrenagem seu uso em uma uma palavra
da era industrial porque eu acredito que
cabe muito bem para as nossas
instituições de ensino superior usa
metáforas na era industrial
hoje essa criança é professor titular da
universidade onde ele trabalha até hoje
professor de mestrado e doutorado está
aqui pra compartilhar uma única uma
única descoberta
lindas que fiz nesses 36 anos com vocês
e essa descoberta é a seguinte as
instituições de ensino superior
em pouco tempo serão absolutamente
irrelevantes e essa argumentação em
torno dessa afirmativa pode ser feita
por exemplo do fato de que passamos
muito rápido do fato pessoal de que a
história se repete em algum momento da
história humana músculos foram
substituídos por engrenagens e nós temos
claros indícios de que sinapses começam
a ser feitas por trocas de bits
nós temos também um outro argumento que
diz o seguinte não é necessário que
ninguém se desloque até um espaço
específico para escutar alguém falar
sobre alguma coisa pra você um artigo da
revista science publicada em 2011 nos
prova que 80% da informação do mundo
está em formato digital disponível na
internet e portanto no bolso de vocês
nos seus smartphones
um outro argumento tem a ver com o
inflacionamento acadêmico
não precisamos pensar em analisar muito
pra saber que formamos muito mais
profissionais do que a sociedade
consegue dar conta consegue absorver e
vejam que se engana quem pensa que isso
é fruto da crise porque não é
as fábricas que começam a voltar para os
estados unidos agora um incentivos
fiscais
elas voltam sim mas não geram empregos
novos
mas esses três argumentos são argumentos
que qualquer um de nós poderia chegar
com tranquilidade
eu quero trazer um argumento novo um
argumento é que prova de forma cabal de
que as instituições em seus interiores
serão irrelevantes em pouco tempo porque
as profissões para os quais nós formamos
os nossos alunos serão feitas no médio
espaço de tempo por robôs robôs que são
inteligentes robôs que trazem em si a
lei de muro instalada
esse senhor guarda humor ele trabalhava
na intel
a intel é uma fábrica de
microprocessadores são os cérebros dos
computadores porque funciona exatamente
como os nossos cérebros recebem
informações processam essas informações
e tomar atitudes em 1965 ele disse o
seguinte a cada 24 meses nós teremos a
capacidade de processamento de
informações dobrada pelo mesmo preço e
sempre os processadores aumente também
nós temos então de 1975 a 2005 um
aumento na ordem de um milhão de vezes
na capacidade de processar informações e
nos próximos 20 anos a contar de 2005
mas a contar de agora faltam oito
aninhos na minha na minha matemática
nós temos microprocessadores nos nossos
bolsos na ordem de 2 milhões de vezes
mais rápidos do que os primeiros
computadores eles já começam a dar
indícios aqui vieram por exemplo o deep
blue em 1997 ganhou do kasparov o maior
enxadrista do mundo em 2011
o ibm watson ganhou um quiz
norte-americano baseado em conhecimentos
gerais em 2017 o ao fiador um algoritmo
de inteligência artificial da google
venceu o campeão mundial de go bom jogo
de tabuleiro altamente complexo milenar
e começa por exemplo o seu tabuleiro em
em branco muito bem mas eu não falo do
robô construído no cinema
norte-americano eu falo de robôs por
exemplo como aqueles que substituíram 60
mil funcionários da foxconn no ano
passado
fala dos robôs que estão instalados no
mac donald's em 2015 na cidade de fênix
que fazem o atendimento de todos os
seres humanos que chegam lá fala dos
robôs que entregam as nossas compras na
amazon quando você faz na amazon eu falo
por exemplo de um robô que constrói uma
casa em um único dia
mas existem outros robôs também existe o
ele que é um robô assistente jurídico
que analisa peças jurídicas pesquisa
absolutamente toda a jurisprudência
sobre aquele processo indica o advogado
o que ele deve fazer eu falo também no
robô chamado da 25 jan do que já fez
mais de 3 milhões de cirurgias no mundo
3 milhões e os dias no mundo sem nenhum
percalço e nós já temos três no brasil
porque eu falo isso porque falo isso pra
ser muito claro qualquer atividade que
têm algum nível de repetição e de
previsibilidade será feita por robôs
eu quero trazer um outro elemento para
vocês eu conheço alguns de vocês
pessoalmente esse onde trabalham não
conheço todos mas eu tenho um certo grau
de segurança em dizer que nos próximos
20 anos
pelo menos 80% das funções que vocês
fizessem hoje não existirão mais para
humanos
aí talvez alguns possam estar pensando
eu vou estar aposentado seu filho não
estará
nós precisamos de fato pensar nisso
portanto adaptar-se é a melhor forma de
morrer lentamente não temos tempos de
adaptação
nós precisamos encarar isso não comum
algo que nos dá medo mas como um
presente
esse é um presente essa percepção de que
as instituições de ensino superior vão
sumir em pouco tempo serão relevantes é
um presente que eu ganho e que agora
compartilho com vocês porque eu consigo
me adaptar me antecipar eu consigo
começar a pensar como eu posso ser
relevante nesse contexto
portanto nós precisamos como
instituições de ensino superior
repensar reconhecer que falhamos
reconhecer que falhamos
logo em seguida precisamos ressignificar
a nossa função ressignificar o que
entendemos por ensino superior para que
possamos então refundar as bases sobre
as quais nós fomos criados e reeducar
esses jovens para o que umberto eco nos
coloca que é ensiná-los a estar juntos
mas principalmente a trabalhar juntos e
já existem instituições que fazem isso
nicole de uma uma escola de engenharia
norte-americana aboliu a mobil
currículos aboliu disciplinas aboliu o
professor da disciplina trabalha 100%
com projetos resoluções e projetos nós
temos mais duas instituições também que
é harvard e mit
as duas melhores instituições do mundo
que trabalham com currículo sim mas
baseado em competências nós precisamos
formar competências e olha só que legal
eles chegam nessa nesse ranking de
melhor melhores universidades do mundo a
partir de um parâmetro por exemplo do
impacto social dos seus ingressos
impacto social dos seus ingressos é o
quanto essas pessoas são relevantes no
mundo o quanto elas são relevantes mas o
senhor uma coisinha ainda que é o
seguinte nós e instituições de ensino
superior
precisamos nos resignemos car para
formar profissionais que possam ser
altamente relevantes a partir da
parceria com os robôs e não apesar dos
robôs mas para isso nós precisamos ter
coragem você tem coragem
as nossas instituições têm coragem não
podemos esquecer que grandes poderes
trazem grandes responsabilidades
o universo o universo está em expansão
você está parado porque vida longa e
próspera e relevante para todos nós
[Aplausos]
[Música]